from the idea that of inversion which
constitutes the essential nature of one
aspect of the supersensible world we
must eliminate the sensuous idea of
fixing the differences in a different
sustaining element and this absolute
notion of the difference must be
represented and understood purely as
inner difference as a repulsion of the
self same as self same from itself and
likeness of the unlike as unlike we have
to think tear change or think antithesis
within the antithesis itself or
contradiction for in the difference
which is an inner difference the
opposite is not merely one of two if it
were it would simply be without being an
opposite but it is the opposite of an
opposite or the other is itself
immediately present in it certainly I
put the opposite here and the other of
which it is the opposite there the
opposite that is on one side is in and
for itself without the other but just
because I am the opposite here in and
for itself it is the opposite of itself
or it has in fact the other immediately
present and thus the supersensible world
which is the inverted world hands at the
same time over arch the other world and
hands it within it it is for itself the
inverted world that is the inversion of
itself it is itself and is its opposite
in one unity only thus is difference as
inner difference or difference in its
own self or a difference as an infinity
in section 160 we're now getting pretty
close to the end of this section of the
phenomenology of spirit that is force
and the understanding so as with the
previous sections we should expect to
see handles starting to draw things in -
you might say a knot starting to tie the
different threads that he's put into
play together we should also expect to
see him getting us ready to move into
the next section what's going to be
developed more thematically in the next
section where he's talking about self
consciousness is going to be brought up
in this section that's why there's a
transition - - from one section to the
other now what he's doing in this
particular paragraph is you might say
lingering over and deepening and making
totally clear a set of metaphysical
points that have to do with the whole
Hegelian system as he's developing it
here phenomenologically as he will show
it to us later in a more systematized
way in in the logic so he's going to
talk about inversion you know so I've
got inversion up here that I've got this
discussion of pure change and what it
leads into these different kinds of you
might say metaphysical perspectives on
things but what's beginning this this
paragraph and what's ending it is
discussion of something that we've been
talking about now for a little bit the
inverted world or the supersensible
world
so let's actually look at that because
that bookends the entire discussion he
says from the idea that of inversion
what you're going to hit in just a
minute which constitutes the essential
nature of one aspect of the
supersensible world so that's important
to focus on here in this paragraph he's
not saying that inversion is the only
characteristic the only aspect of the
supersensible world usually within
Hegelian philosophy any important thing
is going to have a number of different
features a number of different sides so
we shouldn't try to be reductive here
talk about the supersensible world as
merely the inverted world but that is
one important characteristic of it
something that we can develop a lot of
theses or ideas from realizations so
where is he going to go with this where
as we go through all this material where
is it going to conclude at the end of
this paragraph he's gonna say the
supersensible world which is the
inverted world has at the same time over
arch the other world and has it within
it it's encompassed the other world and
what was the other world well it could
be the first supersensible world and
we've already seen that's been rolled
into this and it could also be the
sensible world the world of mere
appearances of show the things that we
are understanding through using concepts
like force or law which we are doing
ourselves by means of the understanding
so there really is only one world it has
different aspects to it we can analyze
that phenomenologically by attending to
consciousness as Hegel has done here
into a world of appearance and then a
supersensible world but they're really
all unfolded together there's no
opposition between them that you know it
would give us a sort of platonic world
of the forms which is real and then you
know world of appearances or material
things which is you know that's not go
off copies or anything like that it's
all one world for Hegel so he says it is
for itself the inverted world inversion
of itself this is a really important
point the inverted world is not simply
an inversion of the world of appearances
or even the world we might say essences
if we like that the first super sensible
world it encompasses them and in doing
so you might say in contaminating that
those other worlds and bringing them in
together showing us that this is all
features of the world that is real it is
in
version not only of them but also of
itself inversion is at its very core
so he says it is itself and its opposite
in one unity this is a thought that
Hegel requires us to think over and over
again a thing being itself and its other
or its opposite or its contradiction in
one unity when we try to do that we have
to we have to exert ourselves mentally
it's not something that is right there
you know low-hanging fruit on the
surface ready for us to grasp so it says
only thus is its difference in ur
difference or difference in its own self
or difference as an infinity this is
going to play an important role this
notion of difference as an infinity is
unlimited as continually becoming
something more so this should caution us
again it's thinking that by you know
writing down a few schemas on the
chalkboard we have you know thoroughly
graphed what Hegel is talking about here
we have to do the work of thinking
through this this is part of to the to
foreshadow of it this is part of what's
going to lead us beyond the
understanding itself and show us the
limits of the understanding now let's
talk about what I put on the board
wouldn't be much point putting it on the
board if we weren't going to so two
different ways of thinking about
inversion that he that he covers in this
paragraph one would be that the
differences involved in the inversion
are fixed in a difference in a different
sustaining element so that they're
treated essentially as you might say
qualifications or modes however you want
to think of it of a substance of
something that remains the same
throughout all of this and remember you
know the classic impulse of metaphysics
was to try to uncover at least one
classic impulse what remains the same in
the course of change so in the course of
inversion which is a type of change here
can the differences be fixed in a
different that
an alien to them something other than
them a different sustaining element
Hangul says no instead we have to
understand the inversion as inner
difference now he's developed this
concept of inner difference for us quite
a lot in this section and also in
previous sections particularly in the
preface so you might want to go back to
the preface or certain parts of the
introduction in order to make sense of
this if this is you know throwing me for
a loop what does it mean for inversion
to be understood as inner difference
well this is stuff that we've seen
already right a repulsion of the
self-same from itself the self-same
doesn't remain self same because part of
the the nature of the self same within
the Hegelian system is to push itself
out there to other itself to create
difference - you might say project
something that is that is not yet so
there's a repulsion within the self same
from itself and then there's a likeness
of the unlike as unlike things that are
unlike also bear a certain relationship
to each other that establishes likeness
that which is unlike itself and here we
should be thinking a little bit had to
what's coming up self consciousness self
consciousness is unlike to itself and
yet it is also a unity so Hinkel is
saying this is what's going on in the
process of inversion remember who's
carrying out the inversion back behind
the scenes it's consciousness or what
part of consciousness the understanding
now after that he's going to have this
great sense where he says here we go we
have to think peer change also peer
changes is vac slowly I'm gonna read the
sentence we must think pure change or
think antithesis within the antithesis
itself or
tradition for in the difference which is
an air difference the opposite is not
merely one of two that's what we're
going to get to here so let's let's
linger over that sentence a little bit
because the the terminology can be
useful to think about and we want to
work our way through this this is really
I would say one of the key sentences not
only in this paragraph but in this
entire section we have to think pure
change or think antithesis within the
antithesis itself or contradiction pure
change change here is vessel that's how
it's being translated now you could
understand that as change or you could
understand that as exchange you know
when you change money you're actually
exchanging one type of bill or I don't
know Cline or whatever for another now
notice too if we use that metaphor we're
not talking about trading one thing that
is what it is in itself you know
irregardless of its relations with
everything else for another thing that
is itself like you know we're going from
red stuff to blue stuff even going from
red to blue stuff presume some sort of
observer who is able to take in red and
blue and make some sense of them
but when we're talking about money
that's why this example is particularly
apt in bringing out some some important
aspects of Hegel's doctrine when we're
talking about money we're talking about
something that has meaning within a
whole system of relations money doesn't
have its meaning even just as a physical
object as the bank note or as the coin
it doesn't have its full meaning in and
of itself intrinsic to itself it has it
only in relation to all the things you
can do with it what you can exchange it
for your own conception of it that guy
over there is conception of it which
isn't necessarily the same as yours
but you assume is the same as yours so
when we're talking about inversion we
should think about the inversions that
Hagel has taught has talked about so far
as occurring within a system of
relations that's part of what it meant
to talk about force or to talk about law
anyway and the understanding you might
say is the force of forces or the law of
laws uniting all these things together
and observing them
so that's change right within pure
change we must he says there think
antithesis within the antithesis itself
antithesis is and Gagan and Gagan zetsu
right yeah if you break this term down
zette so emplacing right and Gagan gayen
means against and the end here is is you
know conjuring something like it like a
distancing or or it's a reinforcement so
I am jetsam it is antithesis but it's
not antithesis in the sense of like
thesis antithesis synthesis the way that
people want to reduce Hagel to it means
two things being set into opposition set
into relief placed against each other
right so I have two pieces of chalk
right and I'm trying to clack them
together
I am I am you know opposing them to each
other by doing so in another way the
chalk is opposed to the eraser is it not
all right this is you know and Hagen
Gazette's this is oppose this is the
antithesis of this you know a certain
way they're both opposed to the
chalkboard we have a whole system of
relations here don't we who actually
does all this this guy here
I spoke my pockets what I'm always
fighting trash certain weight you know
and antithesis of the truck is there
always swallowing it up and then I find
it in my pockets later contradiction
Venus bra is a bit stronger than and
Gagan setzen strictly speaking in formal
logic which Hegel is is taking us far
beyond
contradiction he has to do with two
things not being able to be compatible
not being able to be the case we can
also talk about you know the principle
of the thing not being able to be a and
not a at the same time in the same way
in the same place bla bla bla bla bla
there's all sorts of qualifiers but when
we talk about contradiction we're
bringing to light something that has a
yet even greater sense of opposition
within it then just antithesis just
opposing things to each other so we want
to be able to think this out
remember for Hegel contradiction is
something that doesn't stop us or it
doesn't need to stop us it will stop
many of the individual shapes of
consciousness throughout history and
over the course of things because they
won't develop but it's what pushes the
process itself forward of the
development of consciousness through
human history and culture so he says in
the difference which is an inner
difference the opposite is not merely
one of two so we're actually having I'm
drawing some stuff out here that Hegel
is not explicitly saying in terms of
what he is explicitly saying he's
opposing his viewpoint to what we might
call a substance ontology way of looking
at things Aristotle in his metaphysics
and in many of his other works would
seem to fit this you know a lot of a lot
of thinkers what the Cartesians in in
their own way you know whether we're
talking about Descartes or live nets or
Moll brush or Spinoza they offended that
people like you know the British
empiricist even though they say we have
a very hazy idea of substance they're
still treating things in this way
there's there's a sort of mentality that
goes along with this and when Hegel is
trying to talk about opposition he wants
to resist that at this point of view so
what would this point of view be over
here well it's that the opposite is
merely one of two opposites that's the
way he talks about it what does that
mean the opposite is merely one
two opposites there's you know first of
all the other thing and then it can be
an opposite and these opposites exist in
themselves as what they are before they
become opposites or you know even if
we're talking about you know cosmic
principles like the Greeks thought about
hot and cold being opposites to each
other hot is what it is and then it
happens to be opposed to the cold it's
not as if you know the hot the cold
exists as what they are precisely
because of their opposition no they are
what they are and then because of what
they are they are opposed to each other
extrinsically that is from the outside
another way of thinking about this is
that substances precede relations of
substances so substances are prior
substances exist then they can be in
relations with things those relations
are merely accidental as aristotle said
even if they happen to be you know
properly accidental that was a concept
he Hinton to bring in to make sense of
some things that are particularly
important even if they're closer to the
essence of the thing they're not of the
essence of the thing Hegel wants to get
away from this instead what he says is
the opposite is the opposite of an
opposite no what does that mean that's
kind of a funny way to put things isn't
it the opposite is what it is only by
its opposition to something else and
that opposition is going to in a certain
way proceed at least phenomenologically
the the being of the thing we get to
know things through opposition in large
part so he says the other is immediately
present in the opposite opposites are
not you know totally detached from each
other they're not merely endian gazettes
they're not merely at a distance from
each other by meaning in contradiction
with each other think of it
tradition as something like two people
who can't stand each other and yet love
each other so much that they can't be
without each other either they make each
other miserable but they can't imagine
life apart from each other that's what a
contradiction really is in a galleon
terms even if not in formal logic terms
formal logic is a really hard time by
the way in explaining just how
contradiction works should well it does
work and here's how here's here's what
happens when you do it but getting to
the very ground of what contradiction
would be there's really no answers there
Hegel is trying to provide answers to us
the other is immediately present in it
the opposite is present within its
opposites now you can say here that the
relation of opposites or opposition I
put a little slash here assumes a kind
of priority for Hegel that's what he's
trying to get at now you might say then
you know here would be a mistake in
point of view let's get away from
substance ontology let's get more into
something like process ontology you know
and then you say it's really you know
the relations themselves that matter the
things themselves are just or like nodes
in a network or something like that
Hegel is not going that far he would
consider that swinging too far to the
other extreme that's why he's talking
about an air difference this is a
opposition dynamic this is how
opposition is happening the things
themselves that are opposed the
opposites do matter in the inversion to
get back to what this whole paragraph
was hitting it the inversion that's
taking place through the inverting world
not just the inverted world the
inverting world that is part of the
world that is revealing to us the way
the world is this is inner difference
this is getting us towards what Hegel is
now going to call infinity precisely
because it happens within each
opposition and each opposed member of
the opposition
that through infinity law completes
itself into an imminent necessity and
all the moments of the world of
appearance are taken up into the inner
world that the simple character of laws
infinity means according to what we have
found a that it is self identical but is
also in itself different or it is the
self same which repels itself from
itself or sunders itself into to what
was called simple force duplicates
itself and through its infinity is law
be what is thus directed which
constitutes the parts thought of as in
the law exhibits itself as a stable
existence and if the parts are
considered without the notion of the
inner difference that space and time or
distance and velocity which appears
moments of gravity are just as
indifferent and without a necessary or
relation to one another as to gravity
itself or as this simple gravity is
indifferent to them or again as simple
electricity is indifferent to positive
and negative electricity but see through
the notion of inner difference these
unlike in at different moments space and
time and so forth are a difference which
is no difference or is only a difference
of what is self same and its essence is
unity as positive and negative they
stimulate they stimulate each other into
activity and their being is rather to
posit themselves as not being and to
suspend themselves in the unity the two
distinguished moments both subsist they
are the implicit and are opposites in
themselves that is each is the opposite
of itself each has its other within it
and they are only one unity
one sixty one is is another one of these
retrace our steps summarize and get
ready to move on sorts of paragraphs
here Hegel is talking explicitly about
law but everything that he's saying here
about law can equally apply to force for
the understanding as we've seen law and
force appear to be something different
at first but turn out to be mutually
intertwined with each other so he says
that we need to talk about law as
infinity he says we see that through
infinity law completes itself into an
imminent necessity right you know I
wanted to signal this term imminent
right here the Miller I understand why
he's introducing that that that
particular term he's you know the the
Hegel's German here is you know that
necessity on aims ELPS full and it right
it fulfills itself it perfects itself it
comes to an end it comes to its final
state it comes to where it's supposed to
be on aims elf's you know you can say it
okay now I understand why he's saying
imminent its its imminent in the sense
that not of being imminent within the
world but but present to itself all
there right so that might be a little
bit misleading at first but focused on
when he's talking as law as infinity
that's what this process here is going
to show us he says law completes itself
into a necessity it shows us a necessary
development one that actually in one of
these steps is going to show us how a
lack of necessity gets taken up into
necessity so where necessity doesn't
appear to be consciousness has to probe
a bit further and then it will find it
so he says all the moments of the world
of appearance are taken up into the
inner world what he's describing here is
the process by which these worlds the
world of appearance the inner world or
the inverted world the supersensible
world but how they're coming together
with
each other so we've got a three-step
process
that that's charted out here I'm just
following along with the the designators
that are given in the text the sympathy
says the simple character of law that
the simple character of law is infinity
is unlimited is you know when energy is
is without a barrier without some sort
of end with some sort of here it stops
the fact that law the character of law
is infinity means then it's like it says
self identify so what does that mean
that means that it's also going to be
different because as we've seen nothing
is purely self identical without already
introducing difference as a matter of
fact what we often think of is something
just being identical to itself is really
an abstraction in reality the things
that are self identical are self other
so law separates or sunders or splits
however you want to put it into two laws
organ to multiple ones we've seen a
variety of possibilities for this and
here he's going to say the same thing is
happening with force right what was
called simple force duplicates itself
and through its infinity is what so a
law can take in multiple forces we've
seen this entire dialectic play out of
the law
you know splitting into multiple laws
trying to reincorporate itself into one
single law the entire time by the way
it's been the understanding that's been
carrying that out now the next part of
the movement he says the parts falling
into the law the things that are coming
under the law that are it's determinacy
we could say says what's directed which
constitutes the parts thought of his in
the law exhibits itself as a stable
existence I put stable existences here
because he's talking about multiple
things he gives the examples of can
during motion in space and time or
distance in velocity which appear as
moments of gravity or we might just say
moments of physical you know laws
governing bodies more generally instead
of just gravity these things come to be
treated as they're just what they are
you know space is space time is time
distance this distance velocity is
velocity notice what we're doing they're
worse we're making things self same and
when we do that when we sort of take
them for granted like that in what we
might call the ordinary attitude the the
on dialectical attitude what we do is
we're considering them without the
notion without the concept we're doing
something that the understanding can
take in but something that is not
dialectical something that you know
working them through in terms of the
concept that the notion is going to
reveal as shot through with all sorts of
holes all sorts of things that that
don't turn out to be the way we assume
and they're much more interesting by the
way this means that we treat them as
indifferent to each other and in a
certain way isn't indifferent to the law
itself or the force that the law is
supposed to be expressing and
determining we say that they have no
necessary relation to each other so you
know we saw Hegel talk about this with
you know opposites the positive the
negative I'm gonna just got them there
and there
they're not really that connected with
each other this happen to be opposed to
each other that's no necessary relation
space-time distance velocity you know
you can talk about all these things but
they're really independent of each other
and they're not interrelated and and so
there's really no necessary connection
between them and you know it gives you a
you know a couple of different examples
of this that's not where we want to stop
and that's not where law is infinity is
being stopped but that's the way
a lot of people when they're engaging
with law the law understood in this
sense we can talk about law not only in
terms of physical activity but also in
terms of moral laws that's the way a lot
of people tend to grasp law hey Neal
doesn't stop there he says once we do
introduce the notion the concept of
inner difference these parts were now
he's calling them moments are in fact a
difference that is no difference we've
seen this dynamic before haven't we
we're out what appears to be a
difference turns out you know just sort
of an extrinsic difference turns out not
to be a difference that makes a
difference not to be a difference that
really matters
so he says only a difference of what is
self same and its essence here's the key
thing their essence or their meaning
lies in their unity so now it's no
longer in themselves it's in another and
the other is this unity which is of them
right it's a unifying them together so
he says there's positive and negative
they stimulate each other into activity
their being is rather to posit
themselves as not being and to suspend
themselves in the unity the two
distinguished moments both subsist they
are implicit and opposite in themselves
each is the opposite of itself this is
what law is revealing to us when we work
it through each has its other within it
and they are only one unity it has its
other within it precisely because there
is this unity that here's the question
that Hegel doesn't answer in this
paragraph and we want to think about as
we're moving to other paragraphs where
does this unity come from what gives
this this stuff that unity this has just
happened to show up well that wouldn't
be any sort of necessity what it you
know it's not much of a answer in
metaphysics to say well that's just the
way it is you know even saying well
that's got to be that's the way it's
gotta be that's a little bit more kinds
of necessity that
that's just what we observe just what
what happens to be the case we want to
thank as we're moving forward what is
the ground
what is the producer of this unity